these are lives
yes these are little people
they're little children's lives right
and i think there's something about that
aspect that so shocks the conscience the
ladies of the view speak out on the
devastating mass shooting in texas that
left at least 19 kids and two adults
dead at robb elementary there is no
reason why an 18 year old should have
access to weapons of war that can kill
children in a matter of seconds what are
we doing because we're we're
why are we always at square one with
this on wednesday's show whoopi goldberg
and her co-host joy behar anna navarro
and sunny hostin shared impassioned
pleas to get stricter gun control reform
stop saying it's not it's not guns that
kill people it's people that kill people
it's guns that kill people okay stop
saying the opposite stop saying that
mental illness is behind this but leave
it to whoopi to really speak her mind
slamming republicans including texas
governor greg abbott who signed a law to
ban abortions for women as early as six
weeks into pregnancy let's apply his
abortion laws to guns by deputizing
citizens to sue anyone involved in gun
violence so you sold an ar-15 at the gun
show see you in court does your neighbor
have too big an arsenal call the cops
actually let's invoke some supreme court
logic too alito says abortions not in
the constitution well neither are ar-15s
so i guess the constitution doesn't
cover them either
life is so sacred then stop using guns
to afford young lives and stop using
guns and stop voting for republicans no
don't stop voting for republicans yes
but get better republicans in there this
recent tragedy is the deadliest school
shooting since sandy hook which happened
a decade ago and 10 years later that
shooting is fresh on sunny's mind i
spent yesterday crying
watching this
as a mom
you know and we're going to have nelba
on the show uh later she was one of the
moms who lost her her daughter anna
grace um
uh uh and sandy hook and i realized that
since 2020 guns are the leading cause of
death
of american children in our country
guns they passed cars
cars and swimming pools yeah and it's
just it hurts me so much it's an issue
that resonates with many celebs have
been passionately reacting online
including former the view co-host lisa
ling and rosie o'donnell lisa took to
instagram saying she's heart sick as she
reflected on her own elementary age
children the mom of two wrote in part
this is the biggest pro-life issue in
america and we cannot allow it to
continue meanwhile rosie rants a bit on
tick-tock
they shot kids in
elementary school and
today again
in texas
[Music]
the nra
everyone who's a member of the nra who
doesn't stand up to them the comedian
reflects on our nation's long-standing
history with gun violence and didn't
hold back with her own solutions appeal
the second amendment
that's where i am
appeal the second amendment
you have to earn the right to own a gun
in america
so like this stops happening
i got a kid in third grade
everyone who doesn't feel it
deep in their bones
stand up rise up be counted